hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's a
twelfth of februari today and you're
watching games but news predictably
here's some stuff about video games
first up today whether or not you're
into it it seems that PC gaming is still
totally a thing within video reporting
reckless sales they're positive numbers
were gathered for the three-month sales
period between november and january
where it seems a lot of you are pretty
teen for their new maxwell graphics
cards their quarterly revenue landed at
the 1.25 billion up nine percent from
their previous yearly figures their
profits were helped out by the
availability of 2nd gen GPUs like the
gtx 980 apparently we're all still
upgrading graphics cards enough to help
nvidia push up profits on their geforce
GPUs by one-third to 193 million and
ultimately met them 630 million bucks in
profit for the full-year massive explore
news of coming in drips and drabs but at
least we're getting something here's the
newest info the online multiplayer czar
coming to the new Mass Effect game at
least that's what a recent job
advertisement seems to suggest the ad
calls for an online producer to and I
quote create and champion division of
the multiplayer connected experiences
and online features of the game it's not
a huge surprise since mass effect 3 also
featured multiplayer modes and a bunch
of cross integration with mobile apps
seeing a development director chris win
tweeted out the job ad and also said
that things are getting real now a
phrase which means absolutely nothing
substantial no matter which way you spin
it and trust me I've tried the order
1886 have come out of the shadows today
in an attempt to take the title of game
that everybody is complaining about off
of the bulb here's how it went creative
director rube weerasuriya who I shall
henceforth be informally referring to as
commented on all the controversy
surrounding their approach to visuals
first off he defended their choice to
make the division between gameplay and
cinematics seamless in order to upload
emotion he also defended the
incorporation of QuickTime events into
cinematics saying it's just that level
of interaction that you have even if
it's one button prompt in a cinematic
what it means is that you're still
involved you're still there broo
explained that the plan is to create a
cinematic experience that stands apart
from other games he explains for us it
was important that as the next
generation was here to do something
different not just give people what they
expected not just to say hey here's
every game you've seen until now and
we're just giving you a rehash we wanted
something new let me know down in the
comments if you like what you've seen at
the order 1886 so far or not and why if
you're often more news you can head to
gamespot where we've got bits and pieces
on the longevity of the Far Cry series
and a set of pre-sales those are all the
things that I wanted to tell you about
today but do remember that tomorrow I'll
have my top five stories of the whole
gaming week so I hope to see you then